in every civilized community there's an
outcast from a young age the outcast has
trouble fitting in can sometimes feel
invisible thank you and often has
difficulty finding a mate but despite
this hole the outcasts still searches
for a connection
three from the world of the pig oh my
god what's a pig we request the honor of
your friendship how you doing welcome to
our new frail there's something going on
here these pigs mysterious and weird am
i right that part about them I really
admire I don't trust your opinion is not
me the doctor around yes we have a burn
victim here
that's a hickey on what do we do now
you're asking me you tried to tell us
but we didn't listen we're gonna get
those eggs back come on we're Birds
we're descended from dinosaurs we're not
supposed to be nice
oh yeah point made
I miss you when you die
rest in peace bye first
drop your nuts to move your butts it's
time to get angry
ah she can shoot fireballs out of her
butt
meh
guard there is a real bird in these
[ __ ] bring him to me mm knock in the
walls in the castle come on you guys
we're gonna be working on managing our
anger through movement eagle heron he
got warrior